Jack we've interviewed you a few times I
know in 2011 we interviewed you for some
guy who kills people right it was an
excellent film there Karen black yeah
and then again in 2013 and now we are in
the summer of 2000 excuse me 2016 so in
this current time frame what do you
think the challenges are that
independent artists face that they
didn't when we last spoke to you those
two times interesting well I don't know
I'm it's it's interesting I think the
the the the age-old problem or challenge
of getting money still is the probably
the biggest hurdle I don't I don't see I
don't see it getting easier to get money
I think raising money for an independent
film has always been probably you know
the bane of every filmmakers existence
certainly is for me you know I've never
been any good at raising money and I
think you know with crowdfunding you
know we were talking a little bit about
this with crowdfunding that was an
interesting event that seems to be a
hopeful thing in that you now have a an
avenue to raise money that goes beyond
just going to your uncle and saying can
you give me some money from my my
independent feature but I think also
what you end up having is just like with
everything in this in the
democratization of filmmaking
everybody's doing it so then if
everybody is crowdfunding and does that
make it harder for the individual to get
to people because maybe they've already
given money or it's it's somehow it's
lost its novelty I don't know I I think
in a different way raising money is
still the hardest thing it's just in a
different form no but I guess I mean I'm
hopeful about still hopeful because I
have a project of my own that is
definitely so independent that I don't
think there was any way in hell I would
get typical you know studio or even mini
studio financing and that's like one
film that I would like to try to
crowdfund because it has a political
animal rights slant to it and I think
that that's appropriate for that
I think probably it's it's still maybe
the biggest thing is just coming up with
something valid to say I mean that's
just because now the process of making a
film and it has been four years now the
process of actually getting a film made
is a lot easier if you have the the
minimum amount of funds in order to do
it I mean even if you have a couple
thousand dollars or less you can make a
film you can finish it but that still
comes down to okay so you made a film
and that's an accomplishment but what is
it that you're that you're making so I
guess this may be the storytelling the
the importance of storytelling and
having something an important story
something original something meaningful
becomes even more important the more you
have more movies getting out there
because what's to distinguish your movie
it can't just be well look you got a
movie made on a low budget now that that
in and of itself is not impressive
anymore you know it has to be I think
something specific and it can't be on
ask it can't be a scale thing it can't
be you know it's not like you can wow
them with effects or huge production
value the studio's can't even do that I
went to see x-men whatever the last
x-men movie just to get out of the heat
and I was looking at my wife yesterday I
said you remember anything of what we
just saw and she was like she goes I
can't remember we saw an x-men movie
this was like a day before but moreover
when we were in the audience and it was
you know your standard summer kind of
stuff and you know
midway through the movie there was that
the the the whole you know a city was
being knocked down as it is you know par
for the course not read every movies got
to have a city of being laid waste and
there was no reaction you know I've been
saying this for years now there's as as
well done as the effects were it's just
what are you showing me that I haven't
seen is as effectively done as you're
showing me these action sequences there
was absolutely no
gasping or reaction you know that that's
what those movies are made for so that's
even on the 100 200 million dollar level
I think that that's flatlined even if
the and that's with every dollar they
have that their disposal throwing it at
it so I think it comes down to what is
this story that is going to open
people's eyes or resonate doesn't even
have to be just has to resonate that's
what I mean it just has to be something
that sticks you know I can I mean I'm
curious what was the last film you saw
that that like resonated in that way I'm
like hard press I'm trying to think now
in keys what is well I saw louder than
bombs which was a Norwegian filmmakers
movie which was not one of these summer
blockbusters but it stuck with me I
liked that it reminds me of this this
YouTube documentary that I watched on Ed
Wood so back when the days of like him
before he paired up with Bela Lugosi he
I guess went to a chiropractor who said
okay I'll invest in you but you have to
go to my church and be baptized right
which is in the movie right so it seems
like that if you can find that one
individual but then how long does that
last you know because right right it
doesn't make money back that's right I
don't see I don't think anybody can you
know I mean obviously if you have
somebody invest in your movie you want
them to you want the movie to be
profitable you want them to get their
money back and hopefully that
relationship continues then they become
your benefactor it's like you're proved
you look you proved you didn't just con
the guy you you've made a movie if he
made his money back maybe even made a
little bit of a profit now he's inclined
to give you but there's no way for any
of us at any level to guarantee an
investor that they're going to make
their money and I really feel like
anybody who invests in filmmaking can't
really be investing or a filmmaker can't
really be investing in this idea of
making a huge profit I mean maybe on a
grand scale if you're getting involved
in you know huge franchise like Mission
Impossible I was looking at whatever the
last Mission Impossible movie was and
you could see that there's that there
like the huge Chinese company that's
invested in it and there's like you know
it's like Congo
it's international conglomerate it's
like Godfather three you know it's like
these these things are coming together
to make these movies yes of course
they're and they're interested in profit
or they they insist on profit but I
think somebody who invests in an
independent film should be investing in
it because for the I would say the
thrill of an of investing in something
like a motion picture and getting
involved and observing that process and
it's funny because I had a I did an
interview with joe carnahan you know
director at the gray and and smoking
aces and so forth and we were talking
and we both were saying you you you sort
of want to find that we described as a
unicorn he said it's like it's the
unicorn you want this you know like this
dentist in Idaho who's like a unicorn
who just like shows up with a big bag of
money and all he wants to do is go to
the wrap party you know which is like
the best you know any of us want you
know certainly you don't want I don't
want creative strings attached with
independent financing that would be just
as bad as you know working for a studio
you'd want somebody who goes I will
invest in you as an artist I'm excited
to see what this is about I'm going to
be a producer on the movie or the
executive producer but I'm not going to
give you notes on the cut you know that
kind of stuff that's what I'm looking
for me for that Unicorn I think we're
all probably looking for that if they
exist I don't know do you think they
exist less so now because there are so
many people making films and so it's
kind of like this this one-trick pony
and it's like alright well they invested
a lot of their savings in that and yeah
even though there may be more money
behind them they kind of did that and
possibly I mean if somebody if somebody
invests in a film and maybe they don't
have unlimited resources so this is
their one sort of venture into their
exploration into this and if it turns
out to be a bust or you know like you
know some filmmakers are there are some
people out there who aren't finishers
you know that that don't that don't
deliver
and that's gonna sour somebody you know
if they or the movie turns out to be a
total you know mess and so the investor
goes okay well I did that you know and
now I'm not really interested maybe that
the shine has has worn off when that
happens I don't know but I do think it's
probably harder to locate even harder to
locate because there's so many other
people fishing you know it's like you
got a lot of people on the bank all
casting into this one pool but you know
I don't know like I've never been any
good at this kind of I've never been any
good at at fundraising or finding and I
think most I think most filmmakers can
take heart that that's a difficult
process I mean I just read the book on
Orson Welles is the making of Orson
Welles his last film other side of the
wind and it was actually both in cart
well it was encouraging because he made
it like a student film like he was
making it literally in his backyard out
in alleys with no permits he was
grilling it with this asking for favors
and he was made this is Orson Welles and
he's making a film like like we do at
the most you know the most primal level
when you don't have anything and I was
like well you know this guy at the
end of his career is just finding a way
anyway even though he if anybody
deserved to have infrastructure to
support his creativity he was left
because of so many reasons
just drumming up all this stuff himself
and I said okay great you know and he
always said you know he took him he
could never find the money he spent so
much time you know dining wining and
dining all these people and then no
money we didn't you mention that would
there's like a great scene in Tim
Burton's Ed Wood where they do this put
this whole song and dance on at the
Brown Derby as a backers dinner and you
know they're there in tuxedos and all
this all this output of outpouring of
money just so they can get money and
their cars of limos are driving away and
I guess it's Bela Lugosi how did we do
Eddie and he's like didn't make a cent
didn't make a cent so I think that's
fairly I think that's fairly typical I I
don't and I don't know what the answer
is I don't know I don't know if anybody
does send me an email because I will
know how to do it you know
you